we're taking a bit of a detour of this
lesson
it's a brief one I promise but it's what
we need to keep on progressing in this
topic that we've been started last week
which is binomial theorem remember that
we're gonna get Pascal's triangle and
coefficients and expansions and all that
kind of thing and in order to make
further progress in to understand that
topic I need to tell you about some
numbers like this so what you're looking
at is I guess you could describe it as
functions that are growing or as you can
see growing so I want you to have a look
at each row with me and I'm gonna label
each of these I want you to picture each
one is kind of like the timeline of a
function the timeline minute function so
from left to right you're sort of adding
up and adding off and you'll see how
does this thing grow over time
in fact I suppose if you wanted to give
it a heading you'd call it right that's
that's the idea in my head okay so if
this started you kind of what I actually
have a look at this right here the third
row is actually there is natural place
to start even though it's not the top
this growth through here you can see
well that's just the counting numbers
right one two three four five six seven
eight
if you plotted these what would they
look like on a Cartesian plane you could
do with your arms could you now why it
is just going to look like this isn't it
it's just the y equals x right and it's
just hand up you know rise over run it's
going to be one the grading is one every
time
that's all there is to it okay because
it's a straight line we call it linear
so this is linear growth mix it now you
can see the road below it 2 4 6 8 10 12
14 16 it's growing faster do you agree
like it's clearly gonna be big enough
those by the time you get along however
do you notice if I were to draw this
like here 2 4 6 8 10 etcetera what kind
of a graph would it look like it would
still be straight it would be a steeper
there'd be a higher gradient
but it's still going to be linear do you
agree with that so what you've got here
these two rows are both kinds of linear
growth I guess this is y equals x this
is like white was 2x y equals 3 X 4 X 5
X 100x they're all straight lines does
that make sense okay let's go back up to
copy of the rows here and see if we
understand what's going on
linear growth it grows steadily it never
speeds up it never slows down
can someone tell me how is that
different from this row here what's
going on in this room a look at the gaps
between this last four numbers what's
going on say that again
okay number one it's not like there's a
common gap between the two so I this is
actually going to be a curved play to
graph if we were to do it it won't be
straight because there's not a
consistent gradient from one to another
that's a good first point on how is that
gradient changing though if it's not
staying the same in what way is it
changing I asked you guys to draw or
write rather up to about here right so
if you have a look at that pair of
numbers what's the difference between
that pair of numbers zero point zero
seven yes now if you drop back this is
0.08 this is zero point 1 0 1 2 0 1 8
zero point 3 right so as you go from
left to right do you notice the gaps are
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
it's still growing never slows down them
right up stops but the growth is not
linear it's actually kind of tapering
off and slowly down okay what kind of
shape that is it starts with an L just
like this it's called logarithmic we're
going to spend a lot of time looking at
logs and graphing them this year but you
encountered at the end of last year and
you know
logarithms well in that when you punch
them in what you're getting is well how
big is another brownie and this growth
slows over time okay
moderately grow I know it seems a bit
silly but you know with science
experiments in for headlines you need to
control right so what is this what is
this road is it growing and so no so the
value of this is actually constant so if
you don't have something that's growing
you call it closed it because it's not
changing at all okay so that's kind of
this half of the table this is all quite
slow isn't it well let's put our foot on
the accelerator have a look at this rope
here look at the numbers what are these
limits these are square numbers right so
you remember I said this is the likewise
X this is y equals 2x what's this line
this is y equals x squared
isn't it so if you were to draw this you
know what that looks like wife who is x
squared of course is our parabola so
you've got that steep kind of it's
getting steeper and steeper and steeper
now what you look at this and then I
want you to compare to the next row I
want to be wise gonna be great how look
at the numbers what's this function and
how's it going it's a cubic right and
here's the thing even though this is
square this is cute I suppose I could
put it how important are five etc all of
these kinds of things are the same kind
of growth like these are the same kind
of growth
what is fast in the other obviously but
they cut it in the same family does that
make sense so therefore even though it's
kind of like all right is um is toward
Ross and this short Ross but all
Jarrah's are the same kind of family and
they're all taller than we are right
unless they leave me I don't even know
how tall a really big drop but they're
the same family just like these guys are
the same family
squids cubes and power four or they call
these things stop to the pink look to
the run started
we call these holidays so this is
polynomial bro okay we're almost to the
bottom here I wonder if you're getting
sense of what's going on and if you can
see that I'm going to think these two
together what would you call these last
two murmurs what's going on think about
the function that might be underneath
both of these roads painting by powers
I've got pouch here squared cubed powers
revolve somehow but in what way that's
different to these frozen we just talked
about so this was x squared and this is
X cubed right which is not X square
knots these are square nonces well these
are powers of two right so it's what X
square it's 2 to the X and that makes
this Row 3 DX now of course again this
is faster and I could have 4 DX and 5 DX
but they're all the same family we of
course named that family V that's of an
8 the Exponential's right so you've got
inorder logarithmic growth linear growth
polynomial birth and the fastest kind of
growth that we have here is exponential
and that's why the exponential growth as
um as our same principle has been
created recently is almost a synonym for
it's just growing crazy fast and it's
just taken off like gangbusters and
foods you know it's a positive bright
future for everyone and you can see that
in the numbers you see the numbers and
this is why I asked you to write them
down clearly these guys just sort of
take over these guys over here even
though this might be faster for a little
while the exponential is going to take
over and if you kept on going you see
that happen quite quickly ok now I
actually have one more work on this
here this explains the detour we're
having today if I can aim properly okay
now we went down the road and this is
the last I'd like you to include there
are no more roads to add so please as
long as in this road is an interesting
word because it starts off so innocently
right have a look at say the first four
terms the first four terms um if you
have a look at the first four terms for
most of these guys you have an idea
who's in the lead right like these guys
you can see here yeah of course
they're just trampling it over everyone
the first of all right four four foot
first four terms this road is still
pretty slaughtered right and then look
what happens he just blows the lid off
okay now what is this road this is not
polynomial or an exponential we call
this side factorial growth and that's
gonna be no just have a look at the
numbers how quickly they grow right this
is a big freaking deal math magician
look at that they're like whoa
if it doesn't know same or very often
but this growth is astronomical it's
huge by the time we get to here we're
already in the tens of thousands okay so
therefore if this is kind of like um in
to em if that's not even good right
if you have a label piece you can say
this is just one this is log of n this
is and to n n squared and cubes what am
i up to
what's this road to the end this one
three to the end
this scum and factorial it quote is so
fast mathematicians like the early
symbol that's appropriate is M and an
excavation mark-- and that's the way of
saying hey this thing is really fast
okay it's really freaking fast you
compare it even to things which we sort
of collect really mean as hey this
thing's just taken off it's skyrocketing
this guy leaves the Exponential's in the
dust okay
I mean it takes some time to get started
to be great I use like yeah get me spun
up okay so it takes a little bit of time
one two three four
to really show his true colors but then
he own he leaves everyone okay so now
the question is well if that's the name
of the function that's this one does
that's the notation uh-huh is it they
can get from one number to the next
like you in the next one of my career
yeah yeah very good
so can you see if you have a look at how
to get from one number to the next if
you come back to the first row buddy at
the Lydia Road right
just adding anyone every time right here
you're not adding you are multiplying
and not just are you multiplying but
you're multiplying by bigger and bigger
numbers to you from here to here you
multiply by two here two here you
multiply by
okay and then four and then five and so
on so you can see now the numbers become
what they are are you tracking with me
okay so now you understand
basically what factorial notation is and
what kind of function is now I'm going
to develop a series I've been to an
understanding of what this thing does
and how to manipulate it okay